Salut, aujourd'hui, si vous êtes un vrai
mentalo, vous voyez que :
"beh dis donc, il est habillé comme hier"
Oui mais hier je vous avais prévenu.
Là ce soir je vais être pour la dernière fois en suisse pour mon spectacle au CPO à Ouchy.
Comme je ne sais pas trop comment je vais avoir internet, je prépare cette vidéo-ci à l'avance, au cas où.
Et donc si vous me voyez
c'est que je n'ai pas pu en faire une autre là-bas ,
et du coup je suis en train de
rentrer dans un paradoxe temporel terrible.
Aujourd'hui je vais vous donner
des petites choses qui m'amusent particulièrement
sur les nombres les
chiffres et les codes cachés qu'ils représentent.
Ne fuyez pas !
C'est intéressant !
Les nombres et les chiffres sont partout autour
de nous, depuis notre plus tendre enfance
quand on nous raconte un conte
il y a souvent comme élément fort un chiffre:
Blanche neige et les 7 nains
les trois petits cochons, les trois mousquetaires...
Ils sont aussi toujours
intimement lié au jeu au morpion il
faut avoir trois fois le même symbole
Quand on joue avec des dés, là on est purement dans les chiffres
Les filles qui jouent à la marelle
également et si on se renseigne un petit peu,
on se rend compte également
que les formes anciennes de langage
étaient basées sur les nombres et les chiffres
c'est le cas pour la poésie des tercets
avec trois vers celle des quatrains, où
où là, c'est des strophes de quatres vers
Les pantamétres où là on a des vers qui sont
composées de cinq pieds les
thermomètres...
non là c'est une connerie.
Mais par contre il existe les hexamètres
si on prend un jeu de carte par exemple où là on se dit
un jeu de cartes ok c'est très classique
dans un jeu de cartes,il y a 52 cartes et dans
une année il y a 52 semaines.
Autre chose intéressante: il y a 4 familles:
pique, coeur, carreau, trefle. Et dans une année il y a 4 saisons
il a deux couleurs: les rouge et les noirs et dans une année, il y a la période qui est plutot froide
et la période qui est plutot chaude
Si on fait la somme d'un jeu de carte
as valant un le quatre vaut quatre le 10 vaut 10
avec le valet, la dame et le roi
valant 11 12 et 13
on fait la somme de toutes les cartes,
des 52 cartes
ça nous donne 364
si on ajoute le premier joker s'adonne
365 le nombre de jours qu'il y a dans une année
et si on ajoute le deuxième joker
ça nous fait 366 comme le nombre de
jours dans une année bissextile comme cette année
autre chose intéressante:
en français comme dans beaucoup de langues
si on compte le nombre de lettres
qu'il faut utiliser pour écrire
un deux trois quatre cinq six sept huit
neuf dix valet dame roi as,
Ce nombre de lettres-là est de 52.
Si on se concentre sur les figures,  le valet,
la dame et le roi, il y en a 12 comme le nombre
de mois qu'on a dans une année.
Il y a un petit côté cosmic en fait dans la création du jeu
de cartes qu'on retrouve dans d'autres
jeux d'ailleurs: dans le jeu de go
également il y a un côté création
cosmique puisque le 18 et le 19
au jeu de go pour ceux qui
connaissent renvoient au cycle du soleil
et de la lune et comme les règles de
la plupart de nos jeux
son intrasequement liées aux
nombres et aux chiffres, on se rend compte
que quand on associe les deux, dans les règles,
il y a des choses cachées
qui on été voulues ou pas j'en sais rien
mais si vous prenez par exemple un
cavalier et que vous lui faites des
déplacements infini sur un échiquier de 64 cases
en numérotant les cases en
fonction du parcours et du nombre de
fois où passe le cavalier vous allez
créer des carrés magiques.
Si j'arrive à trouver une image de ça sur internet
vous allez l'avoir en incruste maintenant
Par là, je pense.
Et sinon je couperai la séquence. Pour tout
vous avouer je pourrais vous parler des
nombreux des chiffres et des codes
cachés qui renferment durant des heures.
Je sais pas si ça vous intéresse
particulièrement pour moi c'est lié
aussi à ma manière de faire le
mentalisme, cette compréhension là des
choses qui sont cachés et qu'on peut
comprendre uniquement en étudiant les
choses qui composent ce qui est caché.
Je suis pas sûr que ce soit bien clair cette phrase
Si vous voulez qu'on en parle un peu
plus vous pouvez m'en parler dans
les commentaires je lis
systématiquement les commentaires
j'y répond un petit peu moins qu'avant c'est
vrai mais quoi qu'il arrive je les lis
systématiquement même les commentaires
qui disent "ah ouais c'est vrai tu les lis
et bien si tu lis, réponds à ce message" non j'y réponds parce que je
sais que si je commence à faire ça
alors là je n'en avoir des centaines
mais comme ça mais si ça vous dit que
je fasse une ou deux vidéos peut-être un
peu plus longues sur le sujet je le
ferai avec grand plaisir c'est une
passion. J'espère en tout cas que cette
vidéo là vous aura plû et si c'est le
cas n'hésitez pas également à vous
abonner avant de partir
puisque le mental vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an
donc rendez-vous demain
à 11 heures ! Et oui !
TCHAO !